the fact that you can bring that and
produce that week after week after week
new ideas yes new ideas that people
aren't thinking about yet that then they
think about and go oh okay maybe bitcoin
is [ __ ] i mean we did a bitcoin
thing in the week next week elon musk
pulled out of bitcoin he had said that
you could pay buy teslas and bitcoin i'm
not saying he did that because
we said that but i mean the timing was
kind of system you have no bitcoin
you have an nft bitcoin is so stupid
come on do you have an nft of course not
okay well you're in the you know the
you're i don't have that's even stupider
that what it's and it's all crashing i
mean it's just it's a ponzi scheme it's
preposterous
it's a ponzi scheme but you can make
good money on a ponzi scheme well when
you get in and when you get out not
lately
well eventually it all goes down isn't
it is in the stock market is it stock a
ponzi scheme
no because it's based on companies that
actually have a product to sell no it's
based on i disagree with you the the
well because my dad used to be a stock
salesman and it would that was bricks
and mortar and you can go buy the the uh
yearly sales and the books and the
property that they owned and now ever
since the silicon valley became whatever
it became you're investing in ideas and
the more people that invest the idea the
more value that idea has no you're not
investing in an idea you are investing
in the thought of how good this company
is going to do in the future that's true
the stock market is not based on the
valuation of the company in the present
there are there are tesla was valued at
a much higher level than was ford gm
or
toyota i think were the biggest three at
the time
when they were not selling nearly as
many cars but they could see where it's
going that's what the stock market is
about where it's going but it is a real
company with a real product they make
something and sell something
that is not the case with bitcoin
bitcoin was was started or
cryptocurrency was started as a goof
really by someone we don't know who it
is
somebody who used the
fake name
it was a decentralized
currency so that
really when it started so you could pay
for things and not be detected like it
was all this right it's for criminals it
was when it started it was for criminals
but you know that it's still for
criminals but huma humanity just uh
attaches value to things that really
mean nothing you're wearing a black
t-shirt that could be a black t-shirt
from target you put a ralph lauren
thing on it we just say that that's
worth more but it's still it exists it's
something bitcoin is nothing do you know
how they make they establish bitcoin why
it uses more electricity than some
countries did you know that about
bitcoin i did know that okay because
there are yes mining there are
football field size
buildings that have nothing but super
computers
that are
it's like the game of pick a number from
one to ten except the numbers between
one and infinity
and the person guessing the number is in
the matrix and the person who has
created the number is a fictional person
also and that's how that's a way to run
a currency
you know
matt damon love him but him and the
other celebrities who told people to
get into this they're getting an awful
lot of [ __ ] now and i understand why
they suggested that people get into this
ponzi scheme and
it's it's not going to come out well for
any of them
i think it's not going to come out well
for most of them but some people are
actually
scoring the odd one okay well
seth green got his uh
got his board ape stolen his monkey
yeah
yeah it's just supposed to be uh it's
also very easy for the money to just
disappear if like you forget your
password yeah
that is just gone right but if you
forget where you bank you can lose it
[Music]